cuáles son las soluciones del sistema de
ecuación del sistema de ecuaciones que
igual a un medio de x y 2 x cuadrada
menos ye cuadrada igual a 7 y dice
soluciones pues al graficar las líneas
correspondientes a estas dos ecuaciones
bien pueden interceptarse en dos puntos
distintos
veamos cómo resolver esto tenemos que
igual a un medio de x y 2 x cuadrada
menos ye cuadrada igual a 7 la mejor
manera resolver esto es sustituir una
restricción en la otra restricción es
decir sustituir una ecuación en la otra
ecuación lo que parece más fácil de
hacer es sustituir este valor de ye
igual a un medio de x en la otra
ecuación pues la aie está despejada
tratar de despejar equis o ye de esta
ecuación es más difícil hagamos eso
donde nos encontremos y en esta ecuación
sustituyamos el valor de un medio de x
para posteriormente resolver la ecuación
resultante para x entonces esta ecuación
va a resultar en 2 x
- y al cuadrado pero el valor de ye que
vamos a tomar es este de un medio de x
aquí nos quedaría entonces un medio de x
al cuadrado y esto es igual a 7 vamos a
resolver entonces para x esta ecuación
con un poco de manipulación algebraica
tenemos 2x cuadrada menos un medio al
cuadrado es un cuarto que multiplica a x
cuadrada esto es x cuadrado sobre 4 no
mejor vamos a escribir esto como un
cuarto de x cuadrada y esto es igual a 7
aquí tenemos dos x cuadrada menos un
cuarto de x cuadrada nos va a quedar un
entero tres cuartos de x cuadrada o lo
podemos ver como ocho cuartos de x
cuadrada menos un cuarto de x cuadrada
lo cual resulta en siete cuartos de x
cuadrada que es igual a 7 multiplicando
ambos lados por el recíproco de siete
cuartos es decir multiplicamos el lado
izquierdo por cuatro séptimos y
multiplicamos el lado derecho por cuatro
séptimos y ahora nos queda simplificando
términos del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho nos queda que x cuadrada es
igual a 4
de donde x es igual a 2 o menos 2 si
sacamos la raíz cuadrada de 4 es decir
aquí vamos a tener que x es igual a más
menos la raíz cuadrada de 4 de donde se
obtiene que x es igual a más 2
o x es igual a menos 2 ahora que sabemos
que x es igual a 2 o menos 2 vamos a
sustituir en alguna de estas dos
ecuaciones para obtener los valores de
ya correspondientes a estas x cuando x
es igual a 2 aquí vamos a obtener que y
es igual a 2 entre 2 que es 1 tenemos el
punto 2,1 lo único que hice fue
sustituir el valor de x igualados aquí 2
entre 2 es igual a 1 cuando x es igual a
menos 2 cuando x es igual a menos 2 que
va a ser menos 2 sobre 2 que es igual a
menos 1 y estas dos definitivamente
cumplen con esta restricción y podemos
verificar que también cumplen con esta
restricción cuando x igualados tenemos 2
por 2 al cuadrado 2 por 48 menos 1 al
cuadrado menos 1 es igual a 7 y con x
igual a menos dos menos 2 al cuadro es 4
por 28 menos menos 1 al cuadrado esto
también es igual a 7 así es que una de
las soluciones del sistema de ecuaciones
es el punto de coordenadas x igualados
igual a 1 mientras que la otra solución
es el punto de coordenadas x igual a
menos 2
igual a menos 1